the new film 12 strong yeah this is a
kind of an interesting situation that
doesn't happen a lot it is set in the
immediate post 9/11 moments not just
moments but in the weeks and months
after 9/11 and the person you play
because you were serving at the time the
person that you play in the movie was
real character and in real life he was
your commander in Afghanistan and now
you're playing him yes
that's pretty freaky it's it makes you
realize oh my gosh what a small world
yeah so after 9/11 I I was in man I was
in Manhattan I was in reserve unit there
I got called backup I worked down at
Ground Zero moving rebel by hand I
volunteered to go back on active duty I
was called back to active duty shortly
thereafter so in November of 2001 I went
over to Afghanistan and I reported to
this guy Lieutenant Colonel max Bowers
he was my boss I was a captain at the
time and I worked directly for him I was
on his command element and now I'm
playing him in the movie that's so weird
just bizarre that's a very strange
coincidence at the time he just thought
you were any other guy yeah some small
some Schmo now you're playing him in the
movie and now if you didn't and if you
didn't like him do you didn't like yeah
you could play and like I saw you were
doing your impersonation yes
by the way dynamite and I saw you doing
those earlier I think we can all agree
it's invisible but yeah so when I saw
that I thought you know what yeah I
should have been taped I should have
played it a little more like hey what's
going on around here
I'm talkin outta my ass
more coffee
you